restrictions to try and slow the spread
of the coronavirus are now
in place statewide starting today
restaurants and bars have to operate at
25
capacity down from 50 percent public
gatherings are limited to
50 people or again 25 capacity whichever
is less
private gatherings are limited to 10
people from no more than two households
masks are required everywhere indoors
and outdoors
the restrictions will last three weeks
state agencies will make sure
businesses are complying with the new
restrictions enforcement's going to be
similar to what we saw earlier in the
pandemic
staff are going to inspect businesses
and make sure the rules are followed
posters and other materials are set up
in businesses so customers and workers
can see
store owners are relying on the public
for help
we mostly work with their referrals or
referrals
that we get for employees for business
so
in the background the counties and the
cities are really
doing their business inspections so far
about ten thousand complaints have been
observed and nevada osha found about 90
percent of the places they've gone are
in compliance